continuing our coverage of the scouting
combine 2020 in indianapolis joining us
now a guy whose team has come a long way
in just a few years he's brian goody
coons general manager of the green bay
packers congratulations on the success
and thanks again for some of your time
appreciate it thanks for having me way
to go goodie hey one thing that really
impressed me after the season ended
aaron rodgers going on and on about how
fun the season was and praising you for
bringing in leaders guys like cedaria
smith mercedes lewis not a guy that
you'd really think of as this guy's a
high value free agent does a lot for the
green bay packers so i mean it just
feels like things are clicking from your
perspective how does it feel like things
are actually going yeah i think you know
obviously being matt lafleur's first
year i think we had some culture things
we needed to do i think that was part of
our offseason last year was kind of
focusing a little bit on that and trying
to bring a little bit of a different
culture a little different vibe in the
building and matt and his staff did a
great job with part of that
but as we all know you know culture
really comes from your leaders on your
football team the players and um i think
the thing that i was most excited about
was just how they bought in to what we
were doing
and kind of put those things ahead of
their personal things and that
carried us a long way
it really seemed like it did i mean i i
am amazed at lefleur's leadership
ability and all that i just want to tell
like
when the audible thing came out were you
like oh gosh here we go like or yeah
what was the feeling in the building at
that time well it's like a lot of things
that you know it wasn't you know from
our perspective there was really nothing
to it but you know that in a with a new
head coach in our situation last year
um there was gonna be some of these
things we're gonna have to weather some
of that and um again i think it's really
a credit to matt
the players
and how they handled those situations
because those things could turn into
bigger things and they didn't allow that
to happen and it's a credit to matt
because look the offense works a certain
way but you've got access to aaron
rodgers right so even if the offense
limits what discretion the quarterback
has it's aaron rodgers he can do
whatever he wants to do and we saw the
results right well i think you know the
the best coaches you know really in any
sport you know they're gonna know what
their players can and can't do and
they're gonna tailor it to what they
what they they're good at i think matt
did a really nice job not only with
aaron but with our entire team of kind
of fitting what we could do and and
going that way so um there's there's
only so many good football players out
there and when you have a chance to take
them and acquire them you want to
and if their skill set is a little
different maybe then scheme i think you
got to go that route and um i think our
coaching staff did a hell of a job with
that this year well you personally
deserve some of that credit i mean of
course you were part of lefleur and then
we got to talk about the two studs you
signed on the defensive side of the ball
i mean there's been years of oh the
packers don't get into free agency and
you've killed it here you know talk
about zadarius and preston and kind of
what they brought to your football team
well obviously they're they're pass
rushers right and this is a this in this
league that's really important
um and i think everything that uh
that we kind of saw on those guys last
spring um we thought they were heading
into their prime and they certainly
proved that you know i think they both
had their best year of football uh this
year and we think that they're there's
still room for growth but we you know we
made a concerted effort we signed four
guys
um and we thought
we needed to do that for our football
team and um certainly on defense it
really impacted us you know
tremendously not only those two guys but
adrian amos as well and then you know
the solidifier offensive line i mean our
offensive line was pretty healthy the
entire way billy turner came in elton
jenkins came in and really solidified
our offensive line and made a lot of
things go so um
but on a bigger picture thing you know
the leadership those two guys brought um
the accountability they brought was
really important for us to get to where
we were trying to go
do you know that though when you target
these guys that you're getting yourself
great leaders is there a way to figure
that out ahead of time you just got
lucky you know what you do a lot of work
um
and you know you lose a lot of your our
scouts do a great job you know try to
find these things out but at the end of
the day you don't really ever know when
you bring a player into your building
exactly how they're going to react it's
a new environment it's different players
around them um so there's a part of it
that is just fortunate good fortune and
uh but it's really a credit to those
guys because
they got paid and they could have taken
that a couple different ways and they
never stopped working
they fought through things they had to
follow through the little things that
you always worry about when you pay a
guy are they going to still do those
kind of things to be great and
they really seize their opportunities so
there's some good fortune you never
really know but
i i am proud of our staff and kind of
gathered that information we had we had
a good sense that that might be what how
it unfolded yeah um all right
i'd like to shift to the combine just
for a second sure because it's different
this year it's different for us i know
it's different for you
you know what what are from a gm a
football guy who's been around this so
long what is the what's the plus the you
know the positives and negatives about
this new format we're going you know so
far it's just you know a couple days
into it so far um we had our first
meetings last night uh the meetings we
have a little a few extra minutes um
there's less of them but they're also
there's not 15 in a row you know
sometimes when you get to those 15
interviews in a row you're trying to
remember what the first two were right
you know there's more time i think to
kind of get
um to reflect and kind of like actually
take in what what just happened yeah um
because you don't think we had six last
night we have nine tonight um so i like
that part of it a little bit more time
to spend with the players um early on
here there's been a little bit more
pockets for us to kind of digest some
stuff
but you know so far so good i know that
the informal interviews i've heard i
haven't been down there but i've heard
of have gone well you know a little bit
more organized so so far i think the
changes have been really positive um ask
me at the end of the week yeah but uh i
mean you think this workout workouts at
prime time and thing is going to be a
good thing does that disrupt your life
at all in any way not not for me i
wonder sometimes how the players are
going to feel about
sitting around all day before they go
out and test right you know i think
optimally you want to do that sometime
in morning you know
so that'll be interesting to kind of see
the choices they make um but for for us
in our process so far it hasn't really
changed anything well your ceo mark
murphy's a member of the competition
committee i'm exploring the rumor that
he's trying to ensure that the packers
never have to play in california again
after what happened last year looking
back on that what what do you do in
organization because we had zadaria
smith at the super bowl and he was
candid right i wasn't ready to play in
the super bowl i ran the in the nfc
championship game at san francisco i had
teammates who weren't ready
there was the loss of the charges in la
the two losses in san francisco what do
you do when you look back at last year
to try to figure that out going forward
because you got to go back to santa
clara this year and may have to go back
to the west coast in the post season i
think you always evaluate everything you
know i think during the course of year i
think we went out there a couple days
early in one occasion and changed it up
and i think you're always looking to
tweak to see if you can help your your
players perform but at the end of the
day these guys are professional football
players right and so it's a lot on them
too to be ready to play we're going to
give them
all the resources we can and try to you
know have the schedules and things that
that make it work but the end of the day
they're pro ball players and they've got
to be ready to play no matter what the
circumstances are um and yeah i think we
just had obviously
you know the teams we played out in
california are pretty good teams you
know and um we didn't have our best days
but it's something we'll look at um but
at the end of the day i think it's a
it's a national football you got to be
ready to play no matter what
circumstance kind of it's put before you
would you as a gm
prefer
the
draft before free agency or do you like
the way it is right now because i know i
have some friends and we've talked to a
few coaches over the last few years who
said they would kind of rather it be
that way you know i just get it you know
i know you're a guy that's yeah this is
the way it is and you just keep going
forward but is there any truth to that
you think yeah um you know i haven't put
a lot of thought into that but
um i think with the draft you know the
way we've always looked at it it's a
long-term investment yeah you got to be
careful about trying to fill needs
through the draft right so um i don't
know if it really would change a whole
lot about how we approach it okay you
know right right all right that's good
all right one more combine one for you
because i know you're a historian in a
lot of ways like
give me one guy workout wise where you
just were like i can't believe what i
just saw over the years anybody that
just you put in that short list of like
goodies hall of fame in the workout yeah
the one that just immediately stands out
is uh
byron jones uh braum john
that's right i mean if you've ever had a
chance to watch it it's it's it's uh
it's insane yeah you have to watch it a
bunch of times to see if it's real right
you know um
but uh there's obviously been some
you know i think some pretty impressive
uh performances i think john ross is 40
a couple years ago
you know but but byron jones is uh
broad jump or something i'll never
forget yeah yeah we were talking about
earlier who stunned you the most that
didn't pan out based on what you saw out
of him in the combine a guy that you're
like this guy's a star and it just
didn't work out all time yeah that's
tough um
he's not going to let us know he's never
missed a player right right yeah gm and
the backers right he didn't have to be a
guy he drafted just anybody anybody that
you saw and thought this guy's going to
be a superstar and it just didn't work
out like a mike mamula type of i guess
yeah that's um
i'm just kind of
drawing a blank right now yeah but it's
uh
i've had plenty of swings and whiffs so
there's no doubt about it yeah you're
gonna have it isn't that amazing though
that's the thing about this process no
matter how much time is spent no matter
how much money is allocated to it at the
end of the day it's still a crap shoot
why is that i think you're dealing with
human beings you know and like we
touched on it earlier we were talking
about the free agents here you know
they're super successful in their
environment that they're in and when you
take them out of that environment so
many things change for them and how they
go about it um is it that you know is it
the same drive was the destination to be
drafted yeah there's so many things that
and you're you know we do all this work
and you think it would be a little bit
better odds but it's just not and
obviously there's injury factors too
that i think but nobody looks back and
realizes that there's a lot of injury
things that that really prevent these
guys from reaching their potential but
um
yeah it's just i think it's human beings
and it's uh
um you know
we always talk about if you know if
you're batting 300 you're probably doing
pretty good yeah you know well
you brought up a point that i i think
about a lot and because i had players in
my texas team like this their goal was
to get to texas right they never thought
of the nfl right do you when you have an
interview with a guy like that where
he's like oh my goal is just to get to
you is that a little bit alarming sure
it is it is for sure yeah i think you
know yeah you're always looking for
their driver yeah like why they do what
they do and and um you know if their
driver wants to get to the nfl right and
that's it
yeah you know so
um
but yeah there's
it's but there's also there's so many
instances of guys that you never thought
i had a chance to make it because
whether it's off the field stuff or
whatever and they do so um i think it's
you try to take each individual player
and kind of figure out
um how they're going to fit with your
club right and if that if our
environment is the right environment for
them right and so forth yeah last one
for you aaron rodgers was phenomenal
this year wrong side of 35. how long do
you think he's going to be able to keep
playing at this level yeah i hope he
outlasts me you know
if he could continue to play at the
level he's playing at like you know i
think you're seeing obviously drew brees
tom brady go to to love you know to ages
that we haven't seen
before and with the way aaron takes care
of his body with the physical gifts that
he has i mean
um you know he's throwing the ball as
well as ever you know and i think he's
pretty rejuvenated a little bit you know
and um yeah i'm excited for him to go as
long as he can go um
people have asked me a lot over the last
couple days about you know would you
take a quarterback and of course we
would because we're always in the
quarterback business but we got one of
the best in the business ever done it
and um you know we're gonna ride that as
long as we can you know ride it oh aaron
rodgers
he really was amazing though to hear him
after a playoff loss season's over and
he went on and on about how it's fun
again
and who knows how far can carry him
you're right tom brady's 42 drew brees
is 41 and aaron rodgers no sign
whatsoever of slipping yeah this guy can
keep singing i gotta keep singing my
songs
all right thanks brian gudy coons
packers gm we appreciate some of your
time and all the best moving forward
yeah thanks for having me guys man good
appreciate it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports